Bravo Sei un bambino Hai fatto già
spaccare non me ne sono accorto chi è
Franco va benigna Mattarella con chi
uscirebbe a cena penso con tutte e due
Come si dice Blanco in francese blonde e
Blanco ha spaccato tutto il palco
veramente bravo bravo Hai fatto bene non
si può fare queste cose dei Cugini di
campagna che hanno preso il bonus
Pandora polli bravi e uno solo Colapesce
e Di Martino non hanno cantato ieri Sono
la regina del mondo e ostima e rispetto
delle persone i caratterialmente fatto
così Però poteva permettersi Secondo me
su un palco del genere è successo tutto
di punto in e spunto in Blanco se li
sono piaciuti i Cugini di campagna sono
sempre attuali anche a distanza di tanti
anni quanti anni è parecchio Blanco e
potevi risparmiare pure le piante per me
a Sanremo non verrebbe mai più perché
quelli sono soldi che paghiamo noi
in bianco e nero belli